[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tony biselli
he uh was a hall of fame finalist for
the fifth consecutive year a top ten
finalist
he was also on the sidelines for
westwood one's coverage of super bowl 55
in tampa
and tony joins us now tony thanks for
joining us uh
let me start with you being a great
offensive lineman
watching what kansas city's strategy was
with their offensive line
and why that seemed like there were very
little adjustments there during the game
against that tampa front four
yeah i think it's a great it's a great
point i mean and doesn't it just
highlight the fact that i don't care how
good your quarterback is if you can't
block people up front you have no chance
i mean it reminded me watching that game
back to the
18-0 uh patriots and they were the most
explosive offense we've ever seen
and four guys from the giants ruined the
entire game
and because they couldn't block them and
i was surprised though at kansas city
that they didn't do some more
um stuff horizontally getting the ball
out of his hand quickly early in that
game
all year we've seen them with the wide
receiver screens we've seen them with
jet sweeps
uh kind of getting horizontal and we saw
very little of that
um and i think they put a lot of stress
on that offense line early that was
unneeded
and at the end of the day when they got
behind they just couldn't hold up so
uh i didn't you know it's tough it's
tough going in they had basically three
guys playing backups playing
back up left tackle who's really their
backup right tackle they're starting
right guard back up
now he's the backup right tackle you
bring up your backup right guard so it's
three positions that are weakened i mean
that's hard to
overcome and i'm just surprised that
andy reid eric the enemy didn't have a
better plan to protect those guys
i still think they were loading up for
the big play tony that they
they didn't take you know clyde edwards
lair was averaging six yards per carry
i thought that they could run the
football and the defense that tampa is
playing i mean
you know their safeties were so deep you
got to see that in person
they're basically saying you guys want
the dink and dunk go ahead we're just
not going to let you get behind us here
why wouldn't you just why wouldn't you
take what they were giving you as we
always love to say
yeah we were saying it on the broadcast
i have no idea because if you look at
the first matchup in the first quarter
when
tyra killed 200 yards todd bowles was
aggressive playing a lot of man coverage
coming after him and they were getting
just skewered
um they had no chance todd bowles made
adjustments
coming in i think he knew they could get
pressure with four
so we're going to rush forward we're
going to play two high safeties play a
lot of
we'll play some man underneath with two
eye safeties and he's basically saying
we will not get beat today
deep if you want to dink a duncas if you
want to run if you have the discipline
to do that
so be it but we know we can rush with
more and we know that you're not going
to be this deep and i i i i still didn't
understand why they didn't run the ball
more
and i don't understand why didn't they
test the perimeter with all their speed
and just get the ball out of patrick's
hands because once you do that you then
could have forced todd bowles out of
what he wanted to do
force him to drop that extra safety
force him to play up
and be a more aggressive to stop the
dink and dunk then the shot
is there over the top but to your point
it felt like from the beginning they
said we want the big play
and it just wasn't there and also you
have mahomes with a bad toe
and he ran for over 400 yards just
scrambling
and i thought the defensive philosophy
was let's go up the middle
and let's make him run a little bit here
let's you know
we're going to test his athleticism his
greatness here
and it just it you know tyreek hill
drops the ball
kelsey drops the ball it's they it felt
like they started to panic a little bit
tony
well if that's a guy with a turf bad
turf
he's making plays i've never seen
throwing he's parallel to the line of
scrimmage throwing the ball 20 yards
down the field
and by the way i think it it hit
williams in the hands
it was dropped i mean there was a number
of plays that if they just make them
we might have a different outcome or
much closer game um
there was no juice either dan was the
other thing i was on that chief
sidelines
you know early there was some excitement
as soon as it started going against them
um
there was no juice at all it felt like
the air was let out of the balloon and
they didn't have the answer
for the test and um i thought it was
i because i was waiting the whole time
we said it i'm waiting for what they say
enough's enough let's get going let's go
fast let's get the ball out of our hands
and go and use our speed
they never did it and give tampa credit
because they couldn't block those four
guys up front i mean
and it got it got worse and worse it was
like an avalanche just coming on top of
them
and by the time you got mid third mid to
late third quarter i don't think they
had any answers
he's tony beselli the jaguars radio
color analyst and uh former pro bowl
offensive lineman how easy is it to
block for brady
um i think to me i think it's easier
than vlog i think it's easier to block
for brady than mahomes because you know
where he is at all
at all time all times he's very he gets
the ball out quick
and he's great at working up into the
pocket so as an offensive tackle you
love that because it really takes away
um you can take away the angles like if
you want to go rush up the field that's
fine
i'm gonna take away the power i'm gonna
take away inside and it helps you a lot
um he's just he's spectacular and i
think the other thing and mahomes has
this as well dan
any time as an offensive lineman you
have confidence in the guy behind you
it just makes everything easier makes
you play better you just know that
something good is going to happen
and both those guys have that that
quality and it's uh
i guarantee it's a lot of fun to play
football well brady could step up in the
pocket tony
mahomes could not step up in the pocket
all night long
well he could have i think at times dan
see this is where if i think if you
watch
the tape um there's and this happens all
the time and kurt warner and i talked
about it
my homes will just start backing up even
though okay the right move is to step up
it's his habit he has some of the worst
footwork
i've ever seen but he's so talented he
gets away with it
i mean he can throw off any platform
there's no one else in the league who
can do what he does and a lot of times
where you're saying
hey step up and work the pocket he's
like i'm just going to back up and buy
myself time because i can throw it
with the flick of my wrist 70 yards and
so he does
he's very unconventional i don't think
you want to change it because he's so
dang good um but you know
there weren't now to your point there
were also times he had no chance to
step up because i thought the untold
story that we didn't really focus on
a lot many people are talking about it
because jpp and jack barrett got all the
attention
but if dominic and sue and vida veya
were just bullies in the middle
and they really did press the pocket to
your point and you're on the chief's
sidelines
i was watching the the game last night
re-watching it
it felt like these penalties really got
to them that
that they were taking that to the
sidelines whether it was jones or it was
honey badger and
i don't know they were getting caught up
in smaller details instead of a larger
picture here
what was it like on the sidelines with
that well i was you know we
weren't actually onto the site we're at
in that moat you know in the area right
before so i was like we're like two feet
i was right by the defensive line
actually right behind chris jones in
that group and there was a lot of
chirping
back and forth and there was a lot of at
times people
players having to stand between players
not that it was going to be a fist fight
or anything but they were hollering back
and forth you could see the frustration
at one point i think late in the second
quarter i mean steve spagnola came over
and got the entire defense together
and spent about five minutes kind of
trying to get everyone to calm down
everyone to get on the same page and i
do think those penalties hurt them
um they're but if you go watch them all
year dan they're an aggressive group
they get their hands on receivers and
sometimes you you know you don't get
away with it they didn't get away with
it on uh super bowl sunday well how big
do you think those how legit do you
think those penalties were in the first
half
um i think most of them are right the
one that i thought was interesting was
that last drive right before the half
is the past interference on honey badger
i thought brady was throwing that away
i mean i never i mean it wasn't even in
the same zip code it was so high there's
no one catching that and so
if it's not a catchable ball there's no
chance of a play being made i'm not sure
why they called
pass interference there that'd be the
one i was a little bit like huh um
with that said that drive i don't think
ever should have got down there i was
surprised that andy reid
i understood the first time out he
called uh
at the end of the half the second time
after they got eight yards it was third
and two
why are you calling time out there
because if they get that two yards now
all of a sudden you are at risk of
giving them points
and the way the half was going i just
thought you know what
after they got that you let this thing
run out force bruce aaron to use the
timeout force him
to do it um and and so i i didn't like
that
decision making process and i didn't
like that one call because i thought
ball was not even close to be catchable
top ten finalist
uh for the fifth consecutive year
you know what the party will be even
better tony once it happens
oh yeah it's gonna be great i mean i
always get to this point dan
as you look at it i mean how are you
gonna say anything bad about the five
guys that got in there
i mean charles woodson peyton manning
calvin johnson
fannika and flinch they're all great
players and so yeah would i like to be
there
um absolutely but never take anything
away from them
and i always say you know maybe it's
supposed to be in l.a i want to see
you know maybe you know be even better
being out kind of where i went to
college and got this whole thing started
so
um we'll see how it works out one thing
that has taught me about 2020 dan
don't worry about tomorrow because it
can change quickly just enjoy where
you're at
and uh and so hopefully it happens uh in
the near future and hopefully next year
2022 is the year
thank you buddy uh thanks for uh all
your access here during the year we
appreciate your time as always
damn anytime really appreciate having me
that's tony buselly
he does the jags radio color analyst and
former jags
offensive lineman